hello and welcome to see you playing
take me home Grandmaster take me home no
name we have one game which ended in a
draw I have no particular recollection
of that so we'll see what happened to
you what happens here put the four
nights yeah this is one of those
openings that I don't really like us
black okay against the good GM it's not
such a big deal the media sure thing for
black is to get some kind of winning
ideas and in those lines it's very tough
very tough to learn to do something if
you want to win the game just being a
solid as possible that same night a for
pool no have forgotten everything about
this line this is a sideline not a bad
one not bad at all but i still have
forgotten how it is played white wants
to play a quick see for him and okay
i'll just play normal looking moves and
hope it works out yeah tries to prepare
see foursome and it's just centralized
yeah the thing is the pink the pin is
somewhat somewhat annoying okay what to
do here I could go to 70 i hack Bishop
e3 back to you seven to learn get rid of
the pin or Bishop to b6
and then maybe put it to put it on 26
when an interesting idea for black here
sometimes rupee aid and whoopi form to
tech that age for Bishop and for some
sort of a commitment okay he he is going
for the trade himself so I'm taking this
and now hmm I have an interesting idea
here which I don't know if it is any
good night she fought for Queen g5 Queen
h5 typically primitive play by me I'm
always attracted to those primitive
ideas somehow I don't know why exactly
what I am okay i'm not sure if it makes
any sense to be honest something that
Queen d6 is certainly more reliable ok
so let's do it covering the c5 square
hmm cereally out for c4 yeah I don't
know I'm just I just be annoying about
this year hmm ok so he basically claims
that I cannot take on a to not sure
about it let's see many cases i will be
able to do it like here for example why
not ok when ok ok what is driving the
Queen I can take on c4 first ok I'll
take it and see what happens here if I
take a 2 now whoops is six ok box is six
my position is rather active so i don't
think i can be in any any trouble here
um just one day i can do something
active Liam probably up to eight and
just just centralized
yeah that's not very exciting a rope t8
didn't really didn't really to anything
very dry should position even though now
is in an opinion which okay am I did
probably it doesn't matter much let's
see can I do something here famous last
words okay hey I don't need to lose that
poem but it's nothing wrong about it 94
is that
yeah it's not much else to do simplify
the one minute's time disadvantage is
there is the main issue here in this
position time warning it's slightly
uncomfortable but couldn't really do
much against it given the the time issue
i needed to need it to be quick about
this a little bit yeah i hope my gay
porn is providing some counter play here
did not calculate it to tell the end of
this lemon but i think i'm going i'm
getting i don't get a promotion oh okay
let's see at least his night is very far
off let's see here yeah
this is just a draw objectively speaking
i mean i can still blunder of course or
you can can be no time of course this is
the second option the position itself is
a complete draw ok I will manage this
aim drive Jack not so exciting but I'm
glad to have gotten to draw in at the
end it was certainly a bit critical
after that 97 transformation um yeah I
think raw around here I'm fine for sure
maybe I played it a bit too
conservatively the engine gives c5 with
a pretty pretty nice advantage yeah
maybe this is better contending this
just use the points I was attracted by
this because I thought I should be
better here but I didn't it didn't
materialize probably may I'd probably
made some mistakes around here because I
should never be in a verse ending from
here here only black can be better
because of my better activity the engine
goes Roxy aid instead of this ok maybe
there is some logic yeah this is the
only active route and if I can't ride it
it would be helpful
yeah this gets interesting he has some
weird pieces it's tough to analyze it
sort it's also easy to to be sure here
what happens this is something that the
engine for example is is giving there's
a clear black advantage but this is a
position where everything is
materialized it's all equal which I have
half the more I have more activity and
denied on the enforce or Quitman I can
also just evaporate to completely
nothing even though the engine lost my
position yeah yeah some precise play
probably should net like a little
something but here it was just it was
just equal okay here i should have
played 90 points okay and i didn't see
that one this would have would have
ended any any sort of idea to do
something from provide him just this
over n to draw him okay yeah this is
still ok but maybe that 97 I don't know
why oh I was a bit too h5 I mean okay h5
was a drastic decision i have but i only
had one minute the computer wants to go
g6 and claims it's completely equal yeah
this is the idea then then win this
probably this is better okay what the
engine sets the capture is a mistake and
Tess has King III is bad okay
interesting so this is an a4
hmm funny as Socrates just give me this
is equal it looks pretty terrible f of
neck the a porn looks like it can be
stopped and not so sure on to see porn
very very cool computer defense once you
go night to be ATM engines gives equal
just equal and I would feel pretty bad
here about my chances here computer
chess as we had some times and this is
this is indeed equal I have enough
counter play with the a porn he's just
about stopping it and now and nothing
should happen here on the channel the
King side thank you mmm okay this is a
draw the engine actually wants to give
us an advantage with this which I find
hard to believe and if white goes up
okay now it it's like I couldn't I
cannot believe that this should be an
advantage how can this be and now it
goes down to zero okay dad probably it
is just a drawing I'm getting this he
gets the a pawn yeah maybe I had slight
chance is there but I probably also had
was in some trouble if you would have
played that ending a bit better at least
from a practical point of view that was
pretty bad for black okay well thanks
for watching